i'll give you another use case that i
think will have a profound economic
impact globally
historically an employee gets paid every
two weeks
in the
four largest banks uh this this data
comes from i think 2019.
they made 8 billion
in overdraft fees
so an overdraft means that they tried to
debit your account
and you didn't have any money in there
yeah so the four largest banks made
eight billion dollars from people that
didn't have any money
there's all kinds of ethical and
questions and whatever
part of the problem is when you start to
unlock this and look into it is uh the
folks at a bridge another company
invested in um
they went and did a whole deep dive why
are these people why don't they have
money what is it it's usually not
because they don't have money it's
because they get paid every two weeks so
i get paid on the first and the 15th
on the 10th i won't grow grocery
shopping my car payments on the 11th my
netflix hits on the 12th oh i made a
purchase on the 13th overdraft yep
no real-time updates by the way so you
don't even know where your account is
you think you're fine like trying to
track all the mental math or write it
down get out of here so when i get paid
on the 15th what do i do i pay for the
things that i need and then i just have
budgeted in an overdraft fee
and
my 35 overdraft fee every month
adds up and so does all the other
millions of americans and ends up being
8 billion top 4 companies oh my god now
why can't we pay people at the end of
every day
why when you leave work today don't you
get paid why does it only once
you know or twice a month was a
technology problem
right and sure there are economic
reasons why the company wants to hold
the money rather than give it to you and
they earn interest or whatever right
but it's mainly a technology problem
because there's two components one is
how do i actually pay you every day what
am i gonna why are my own payroll every
day like that's pretty crazy right that
seems inefficient
and two how do i keep track of it how do
i do the accounting around well did tom
get paid did he actually get it okay he
got it all right who didn't get paid
today who didn't come into work okay we
don't pay them whatever so
when you bring the cost of sending small
amounts of money to xero
and you do it in a frictionless
censorship resistant way
you get what you call streaming payments
so kind of the most economic prosperity
is now i can pay every one of my
employees at the end of every day
well if i do that
how much better financial position are
they going to be in just that alone
would drastically lift millions of
people around the world into a better
financial position just pay people at
the end of every day and there's
companies that are working on this some
of them are using crypto real some of
them trying to do other stuff whatever
but that when you drop the technology
cost to zero to send money is
life-changing hey you did you like this
video great make sure you subscribe like
the video and see you next time